quelques coups de pelle une dameuse est
un peu de sable une quinzaine de minutes
suffisent pour reboucher ces trous sur
la chaussée
cette réparation rapplique vient combler
les nombreux nids-de-poule de l'hiver
une solution provisoire avant la mise en
place de réparation fait et rennes le
conseil général des yvelines vient
d'annoncer la mise en place d'un
programme exceptionnel sur le
département un million d'euros y seront
consacrés
c'est deux fois plus que l'année
dernière la cause la météo sur le cours
du mois de février on a une température
moyenne inférieurs de 2 degrés à haute
température constatés l'an dernier
amy et une pluviométrie supérieure de
l'ordre de 25%
donc la combinaison de ces deux
phénomènes ont amené un nombre important
de dégradations localisés sur les
chaussées des nids-de-poule qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 15 cm de profondeur pour
saint-quentin aussi c'est un véritable
investissement le budget a augmenté de
65% par rapport à l'année dernière en
passant de 70 à 130 milles euros
car si le département s'occupe des
routes départementales c'est la
communauté d'agglomération qui est
responsable des 200 km de voies de
gestion commune les voit effectivement
les plus anciennes ont un peu plus
souffert puisqu'elle commence à voir une
certaine des suspects ou la structure au
niveau de l'enrobé et puis vous avez
d'éoliennes circulation plus forte
on a une zone par exemple que la zone
d'activités de trappes et long cou qui
est particulièrement touchée parce que
nos mots polis les réparations
définitives viennent d'être mises en
place elles sont censés tenir pendant
une dizaine d'années